- Comment vous trouvez, ici,
l'hôpital? C'est vrai... qu'on
est toujours mieux chez soi, là.
- Chaque petit pas exige
beaucoup de patience.
Mais ce travail de l'infirmière
Joelle Jomo est essentiel.
JOELLE DJOMO, infirmière
- Lorsque le patient reste
longtemps couché, là, il perd
beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup
en muscles, et tout là.
Donc on essaie de le faire,
plus on les fait bouger, plus
ils sortent aussi plus vite,
- Parce que la plupart
des patients souhaitent
quitter l'hôpital.
DR BAO PHAN, médecin,
Hôpital de Verdun
- Notre objectif, c'est
de déterminer quels sont
les obstacles à son retour
à domicile.
Quand les patients occupent
des lits, bien malheureusement,
ça engorge l'hôpital et
tousles services sont
un peu ralentis.
- En ce moment, environ
600 patilis restent
dans les hôpitaux alors qu'ils
devraient être ailleurs.
Au CIUSSS du Centre-Sud
de Montréal, ils représentent
presque 10 % des patients
hospitalisés. On a même réouvert
une aile fermée pour en héberger
une trentaine.
- Avez-vous bien mangé, ce midi?
- Des gens âgés, qui ne peuvent
plus retourner chez eux après
leur séjour à l'hôpital.
RINDA HARTNER, cheffe unité
tempo. Hôpital Notre-Dame
- Ils attendent une place
dans une ressource intermédiaire
ou dans une résidence
pour personnes âgées ou dagées s
un CHSLD, donc en attendant,
on a créé cette unité pour
laisser la place sur
les unités actives; en médecine,
en chirurgie.
- L'autre solution est
que les soignants se rendent
chez les patients.
assoyez-vous là. Tenez,
puis moi je vais m'asseoir sur
le petit divan à côté de vous.
- Dr Eveline Gaillardetz
traite Jeanne Dumont Morissette
dans sa résidence pour personne.
- Bien oui, c'est bien mieux,
c'est moins compliqué.
- L'ex-enseignante a eu la COVëC
lui a donné tous ses soins
à la résidence.
Dre EVELINE GAILLARDETZ,
médecin, CIUSSS
- Donc, il a fallu faire
un épisode de soins, comme
un peu on voit à l'hôpital :
faire des prises de sang,
ajuster des médicaments...
- Pas question pour elle
d'aller à l'hôpital.
JEANNE DUMONT-MORISSETTE
- Il y avait beaucoup de monde
qui était allé à l'hôpital à
ce moment-là et puis il pouvait
pas y avoir beaucoup de
services. Je me su
ici, je suis bien.
- On tente aussi d'accélérer
les congés de l'hôpital
pour les patients comme
Réjean Lsouffre
d'un cancer en phase terminale.
- Êtes-vous content d'avoir eu
votre oxygène chez vous?
- Oui.
fournit la bonbonne
d'oxygène.
- Là, je vais prendre votre
pression.
personnel comme Mélissa
Leboeuf, infirmière.
- J'aime ça, parce que tu as
quelqu'un qui vient te voir
Ils sont toujours là!
Ils me lâchent pas!
- On lui évite des allers-
retours à l'hôpital et on
préserve ainsi des ressource
pour les chirurgies.
Ici, les soins à domicile,
c'est la clé pour désengorger
les hôpitaux.
- On est au début de cette vague
de vieillissement
de la population, on est
au début de ce tsunami gris.
Fait que c'est clair que si
les soins à domicile sont pas
davantage déployése
un mur, ça c'est évident, là.
- Et pour l'instant,
ça permettra probablement
à Réjean de mourir à la maison,
comme il le souhaite.- En premis
l'assistance à mourir, mais là,
j'ai cha